[Music]
in ridiculous claim news
aren't they all ha I don't know was your
claim ridiculous when you hurt your
finger and no no it was debunked live
debunking submitted by batter up swing
then that Rookie of the Year some [ __ ]
it's all da love Sandlot all true
seventh-inning song they say you turn 17
stresses right I forgot that's an
awesome song and everyone stands up
y'all seeing it no and they all like do
this [ __ ] yeah I get drunk drunk we're
doing the railway a religious scholar
tried to block yoga from Russian prisons
stating it would make the inmates turn
gay yoga does have an effect on the gay
stuff dude I remember being a high
school and doing yoga at a PE class and
I was like nah dude not so fine
that's such a sine diagonal thing to do
we were all too cool and [ __ ] you know I
mean was so hard at the down-dog it like
hurt me it was hard like my arm so much
I was like this is the resting positions
crazy the first time I did yoga was
Bikram yoga and it was a fat indian dude
teaching the class but he was the most
flexible do I ever Saints and there was
a lot of Rosa yoga pants we had a sub
who was a part-time yoga instructor so
she has to do yoga for a day but we were
always you cool with guys no way but
then we got to see chicks butts in front
of us more like whoa wait a Miss is good
it was like a duality yeah yeah in
college we took a like meditation type
class and we do yoga as well but I've
stopped doing it because P would fall
asleep after like laying down yeah
for sure Falls pushing College name when
you're a mac stress and [ __ ] and you're
hungover and stuff you get to close your
eyes so I had classmates that will come
to school and pajamas with pillows in
every period dude where'd you go to
college no high school eyes oh yeah I
remember that phase remember when like
going to school and your pajamas was
cool like I really have lockers and
slippers and stuff like fluffy like that
that was halluf on alright so there's
this Russian prison where authorities
have reinstated yoga after just missing
a claim by a religious scholar Sam at
the practice what religion uh you don't
know yogi and Theological someone
checked out the jail and they were like
that's gay position in their life mmm
that's gay homie so you're saying that I
pictured it like an Orthodox Christian
outfit do you know how they look like
old ancient like priests and [ __ ] and
then they have the [ __ ] smoke that
there they're going down the [ __ ]
jail hall like this and they're like
that's so gay was having a meditative
time in there bro that is gay bro come
on that's that's [ __ ] gay boy I've
heard somebody say this [ __ ] before I
get a clubs or something I've heard that
kind of exactly what you're doing Hannah
I've heard that in real life yeah so
this beautiful professor named Alexander
Dworkin wrote a document suggesting that
yoga could cause uncontrolled sexual
arousal and homosexuality in detention
centers leading to riot
so rioting sex they're not rioting there
but [ __ ] all day so they're raping in
and out is nothing to do with sex it's
about power this is a conspiracy
there is no consent sex in prison the
precinct gay no there's consensual sex
in prison
the priest is a closeted gay yeah
probably when he washed the yoga session
and all the dudes were in hot yoga pants
yeah bending over he got hard and he
said oh no if I'm [ __ ] horny off it
is someone else my beginning mad horny
as well he said can we be real for a
second whose nipples didn't get hard
watching the [ __ ] and it was like what
the [ __ ] you talking music they're like
well you're not being honest
he was like it mates in Lululemon make
me hard how about you guys yeah yeah
yeah okay this is too gay
it's almost always that [ __ ] like some
guy like being you know repressed in his
own field I'll [ __ ] and then he's got to
come down on everybody about his own
[ __ ] most homophobic dudes tend to be
the gayest the most a study on um they
got a bunch of dudes that that they
wrote this servitor like okay they found
the most homophobic guys that that claim
that they're super anti-gay and all this
stuff and then they got a bunch of guys
that that were like I'm cool with it I'm
straight but I'm cool with it right
but they both claim to be straight and
then they they [ __ ] got like like
like [ __ ] like I don't know like I
eat like a dick meter or some [ __ ] right
they wrapped around this thing you know
to check their like heart rate a
reckoner all that [ __ ] right dick I
don't know what it's called but it's
like wrapped around dick and [ __ ] and
then so to be made and watch gay porn
and majority of the guys that claim to
be homo like like anti gay and all that
stuff they got rock-hard solid and horny
blood pressure up all that stuff when
they're watching gay bored and then the
straight guys that were just indifferent
to like how they feel about gays or
whatever nothing if you read the study
the scientists end and think these guys
got rock-hard that's how I translated
though it's like yeah they got rap rock
hard yep
yes so then one part looked up gay porn
to see if he was gay like he was yeah
actually doing a scientific thing on
science has he he wanted to make sure he
was like when he was claiming it yeah if
he was straight bi or gay right so he
was watching porn and then in the middle
he got curious so he started watching
game
beating off to that and he's like no
matter how hard he tried he got limp and
he didn't didn't turn him on did he give
it a real shot did he do - he's a gay
porn what does that make me then because
you're kind of gay because I get aroused
by watching girls but I would never want
to actually yeah that's what the console
and forgot which class it was but my one
of my teachers was it was I call I will
psychology before I forgot what it was
we were talking about the difference in
sexuality between male and female and
how we our experiences are definitely
different right because of how we raised
and how we look at things and just our
biology but she was saying like women
tend to be more closer to the by
spectrum because what turns them on is
very different from like guys can
they're simpletons we're very rigid yeah
it's the again so you can see a guy in a
yoga pants and if they look like a girl
we'll get hard my theory about that is
that you like the essence of whatever
porn you're watching so if you're
watching and let's be important like
they're really romantic or they're
softly it's like very soft and caressing
no that's it how is it when you you know
I realize it's not really even that like
I just like watching a girl masturbate
on her own just to watch it I got an
even masturbate while I'm watching it
but then that turns me on and then I get
to town on myself I put that [ __ ] away
and then I like maybe because that
liberated person that's having that
intimate moment with themselves is like
it's like you can see yourself doing
that yeah you're unlocking what your
repressed sexual feelings by watching
this person yeah they're oppressed I
don't watch a guy jack off and go [ __ ]
I'm gonna do that later where do i I
don't know what it's weird like where I
feel like like I said like guys
experience and watch porn differently
from women well the first porn I watched
was diet gay porn because I like I had
tried having sex before and it hurts so
much that the thought of dicks go it
like rapidly going into a vagina was
like [ __ ] traumatizing so but I could
watch two guys do it because it still
had the dominance thing but it wasn't
like I was getting hurt at all
you know what that's probably what it is
so when you want right yeah [ __ ]
right when you watch two guys but then
if you like the first experience I had
but but but if you okay so like if you
watch porn you know it's not for the
email because you look at your life that
doesn't feel good no that's not true so
then I watch gangbang porn now and I
watched the girl because I like to see
her getting completely utterly dominated
but I would not like to be gangbangs I'm
just like the dominance feeling in there
that she's completely getting dominated
and I like to watch guys [ __ ] other guys
while I sit there and I steal my [ __ ]
nerves and I watch it and and if I don't
get a boner that I want my [ __ ] win
again only win yeah I don't know I can't
even explain it cuz yeah like I think
the experience is completely just
different like I wouldn't hire you like
imagine that you're the guy like yeah
being this girl yeah well I think that's
mainly what the guys do that makes me
yeah I imagine I'm pipe in this chick
and then is so funny yeah you lamp I
think is like it could be a black guy or
a white guy or whatever it's like for
that day I'm black you know why they're
my brothers dude whoever's [ __ ] that
chick is my brother it's like hey I'm
just gonna borrow your body for a minute
you know that's me you've never thought
of it that way I've never seen an Asian
guy [ __ ] Warren no except for it when
you're watching like Japanese porn or
something weird like blur it out yeah
and then usually the guy just looks like
just as scared as the girl yeah like
some Asian port where like the girls
like are like rut like they're screaming
and it sounds like they're really sad
and getting hurt alright this is just
the sex noise they make I agree there is
a category rate porn I don't know but
like you know like have you boys my mind
though how are different cultures yeah
sex is expressed so differently than
culture yeah that's just weird and then
women at their prime is expressed
differently in different right what is
the considered prime women right like
like I don't know
I think in Japanese it's like high
school or college or they might be the
same here but like they're still also
you know women that are like in their
thirties that are still hot as hell I'd
like yeah yeah one time I was doing my
experiment where I watched dudes [ __ ]
and then I got a little bit hard but
then I talked myself out of it I'm good
at it nice I even watch barely get
harmed doing them I thought I was
watching lesbian bored and then the girl
goes dad like they're kissing and then
the girl goes down and she starts
sucking the ladies dig one of my
favorite stories is he's watching a
gangbang thing right and then all of
sudden he says he says that a guy turns
his head and then another guy shows his
dick into the guys about [ __ ]
bro for that one yeah I just it was like
it was like a threesome right and the
guys like hell yeah then they're doing
it and in the guy go
oh yeah and she comes up and he grabs
his buddies thick it starts sucking it
then I was like I didn't sign up for
this I didn't sign just always imagine
this guy sitting in his crew below with
the blue glow in his face and these are
sitting there he's like yeah yeah and
then he's like that's exactly right
yep I love it I didn't sign up for this
[ __ ] though
[Music]